this was the moment a lone gunman
stormed into the Shrine in Shiraz and
opened fire he killed at least one
person and injured dozens of people
Witnesses said it happened quickly
[Music]
I saw people were running towards the
exit who were injured I didn't know what
had happened I saw everyone around me
had run away
the gunman was arrested on the scene and
has been identified as a citizen of
Tajikistan the head of Iran Judiciary
says another eight men have been
arrested in connection with Sunday's
attack all of them are foreign Nationals
tajikistan's foreign minister says it
has yet to receive the documentation
about the suspect from Iranian officials
to verify his identity Iran and
Tajikistan have had good relations since
the former Soviet Republic declared
independence in 1991 and Tehran is its
second biggest foreign investor after
China
Iran's foreign Ministry spokesman
provided one possible motive for the
attack
unfortunately some world powers have
been using these terrorist groups as a
means of gaining influence to have a
presence in the region and to make
political and security changes here
sentiments shared by the spokesperson of
the Revolutionary guard who accuses
foreign spy agencies of being involved
in what the government is calling a
terrorist attack with the goal of
creating division between Iran and its
neighboring countries
this is not the first time structure of
shrine has been attacked last October
three gunmen stormed its grounds killing
13 people this 12th century Shrine is
the third most important in the country
and now officials will be looking to
increase their security and find out
more about the nine men they accuse of
carrying out this attack
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Tehran
foreign